[Music]
hey y'all time
for another tomes of terror now the book
i'm going to be talking about
this time this is interesting because i
think this is the first time that
somebody in the youtube comments of one
of my other tombs of terror videos like
recommended a book
and i'm pretty sure i never i mean the
guy's name sounds familiar but i don't
think i've ever read anything of his
before
um so this was the book that was
recommended and it is asylum
by patrick mcgrath now this came out
in 1997. uh patrick mcgrath is a
british writer so this is uh set in the
uk
it's also set in i believe it said in
1959 i don't remember if they said in
the book like outright that that's when
it was said but when i looked it up like
on wikipedia and stuff like that's
generally like when this is set now i
will say this
is a i would call it like a
gothic thriller more than like
a horror horror type of thing it's more
like on the psychological end of things
and um i will say at the outset it is
very very bleak
it is very depressing but that said
i found it like really really compelling
even though like a lot of the stuff that
happens in it
i don't want to say it's like melodrama
necessarily but there's like a lot of
kind of crazy [ __ ] that goes on in this
and um you know it's a little bit it's
it's kind of like over rotter over the
top but that's kind of what gothic
literature
is so i'm not really you know all that
bothered where i'm criticizing it for
that because it is like within the
constraints of that genre
um and also another thing that i figured
that i found out was that
i guess in 2005 they did a film
adaptation of this
uh and had like natasha richardson and i
think like sir anne mckellen was in
it and it sounded like good but then
when i went to the wikipedia page and it
sounded like it stuck pretty close to
the book except
for the end was a little bit different
but uh apparently it got like
savaged by critics they just said it was
terrible and it's just like it was just
a horrible like adaptation of the novel
so now i kind of want to see it like
just to see like what
how could it be that bad like with those
good actors i don't really know
so what this book is about as i said
it's said in the uk i think it's in the
late 50s or early 60s
was the impression that i got so there's
this married couple
max and stella raphael and max raphael
gets a job at this mental hospital
that's kind of i mean they're from
london and they're kind of like very
urbane and everything
um this hospital is kind of a little bit
out of the way like not super far from
london but it's a little bit out in the
sticks
so um stella is like apparently not
super happy that they've had to leave
their kind of city life behind and now
they're out here
you know on this farm or whatever but
they give the family a house they also
have a son named charlie who i believe
is uh nine or ten years old
so they kind of try to settle in like
max settles into his job
and stella just kind of like hangs out
you know what i mean because she doesn't
really
have much of anything she does like they
don't have a hou they have a housekeeper
but it's like she
does most of the [ __ ] herself like
cleaning and cooking and everything you
know
like like a stay-at-home wife would have
done back then
now it comes to pass that this
uh particular patient who is at the
hospital
named edgar stark he is
an artist and he is also
um they say that he's like schizophrenic
or something but he's also like
really violent he has been
institutionalized
because he basically um
killed his wife ruth like in a really
really horrific
way which i won't spoil but um yeah so
he killed his wife and he got
institutionalized
now he also does like construction and
he's like a really good handyman and
stuff
so it comes to pass that edgar is
um he starts working and restoring
this i think it's like a greenhouse or
something like that that's like on the
property of the house that um that max
and stella
are living in because like i said it's
like it's all on the same grounds i
guess because there's like the hospital
and then like whoever is working there
like you know the superintendent or
what have you they have their own like
quarters like their own house on the
grounds and they can do what they want
with it so
max like gets it into his head he's like
oh we need to restore the garden and we
need to restore the greenhouse
so they hire edgar stark to do it or
they have because they have him kind of
on a day program because they think that
it's going to help him out
now i will mention that pretty much this
entire book
is narrated and i thought this was like
an interesting
um choice it's narrated from the point
of view of
peter cleave who is another psychiatrist
that works at this hospital and edgar
stark is his patient
and he's also friends with max and
stella
so it's kind of interesting because
you're seeing
these events unfold like through someone
else's eyes but who has knowledge of
like the [ __ ] because he's a
psychiatrist
and he understands like the reasons why
people are doing things
and also because him and stella are such
good friends like you know later on as
the [ __ ]
really starts to hit the fan um she like
starts confiding in him like about her
feelings and things so he kind of like
gets inside of her head
um also so i thought that was a really
interesting narrative choice
i really dug it i think it because i
think it gave because like i said the
stuff that happens
it's very it's a very gothic novel in
the sense that
you know the stuff that happens is like
i don't want to say it's wildly
unbelievable because i
have heard of things like this happening
but it is a little bit like
melodramatic or like overwrought so i
think it's cool
that you almost have like the stuff
described from like one remove
in that way it kind of reminded me of
like ann river sit-ons maybe i'm not
sure if i'm pronouncing her name
last name right i pronounce it different
every time i say it like her
her uh book the house next door
which you know had all these kind of
like overwrought elements in it but the
way that it's told
is so like matter-of-fact that it just
seems like you that you just like go
along with it
so this kind of like reminded me of that
a little bit so basically what ends up
happening
edgar stark this violent uh
not necessarily a psychopath but he's
not
right okay um so he's working on
the greenhouse like by the you know
the raphael household and stella
being bored with her boring ass husband
she decides she's gonna get a little
piece of that
psychopath over there unwisely as it
turns out
um so they start an affair like i said i
don't really want to spoil
like what the [ __ ] happens in this book
but let's just say that [ __ ] does not
go well at all
she ends up pretty much ruining several
lives
people die it's just like just because
she wanted
like some new dick and she
apparently got really really into edgar
stark even though she knew
that he was like a psycho and what she
knew what he had done to his previous
wife
but she just like hit like his artistic
temperament and all this other kind of
stuff and she was just
about it you know what i mean so it was
like very passionate and it seemed like
maybe he was feeling the same [ __ ] but
it's hard to tell because like i said
this is told from the point of view of
peter cleave who was a psychiatrist who
knows all of them and like was sort of
like tangentially involved in like the
whole situation
so you're getting like a little bit of
an outsider's perspective but an
outsider that actually kind of
knew what was going on and knew what was
going on in people's heads
but that said the really interesting
thing about this book
is that it's got like a lot of
layers going on because like i said you
don't know
these are all psychiatrists and people
that are like you know that know
psychiatrists
so i feel like i don't want to say it's
necessarily like an unreliable narrator
situation
but they kind of it's kind of left open
for that interpretation
because it could be that particularly
stella who's kind of like the focus of
most of them i mean that's who they're
usually following and that's who he's
usually talking about
um and he kind of gets inside her head
but the more
it goes on the more you're kind of like
well
is he like seeing her psychologically
correctly like
is he really you know getting into any
insight
into what her feelings are or what her
reasoning is for doing
the crazy [ __ ] that she does which ends
up like ruining all these people's lives
or is he just being manipulated
you know what i mean because she kind of
she's married to a psychiatrist she's
friends with psychiatrists and she kind
of knows what's going
on um and she knows like what they
what particular things they would be
looking for and stuff so it's almost
kind of like
everybody in this book is like
manipulating somebody else
but you're not entirely sure you're
never entirely sure when it's happening
or what you know what i mean
so it's kind of like that it's like a
really intriguing
psychological study of let's be honest
a lot of really really unlikable people
i mean
but that's not a ding against the book
though that everybody in this book
particularly stella who is like the main
character even though in some ways i
guess you could call her a victim
because like i said i should have all
the men in this book are kind of like
manipulating her but she's kind of
manipulating people too
it's kind of hard to say because her
thought process
processes and like why she ends up doing
the [ __ ] that she does
and then particularly like later on like
when everything has come like [ __ ]
crashing down just like her entire
world and everybody else's world like
you know in this little small
pocket of wherever she almost seems like
she doesn't really give a [ __ ] you know
what i mean and it's she's just
like very but the thing about it though
is that she might be like suffering from
depression
also so it's like it's almost like she
can't like it's an illness and she can't
control like the way she feels about
[ __ ]
so she's a she's a hard character to
like
she's a hard character to root for
because
the [ __ ] that she does and the [ __ ] that
she says like to peter cleave the guy
that's narrating the book
um about why like how she feels about
what she did and all this other stuff
it makes you really kind of hate her but
then because she just seems like a
horrible person
but then on the other hand you can kind
of see too like when you step back like
after i finished the book
and i was like thinking about it and
then like i read some other people's
like
um takes on it and [ __ ] like that and i
was like when you kind of start thinking
about the story
you're kind of like maybe like i said i
don't want to call her the victim
because she had agency she knew what she
was doing
but it's almost kind of like everybody
in this book
was shitty and it's almost kind of like
she didn't know like how to react to
that situation because they were all
trying to manipulate her
into particular things also i mean edgar
stark
even though you could say maybe he did
love her they don't you know you don't
really know
but you know he might have been
manipulating her you know for his own
ends you know which comes to pass later
in the book max
he didn't seem like actively hostile
toward her but he for sure
was like neglectful like he didn't
really you know
it's like they heart they never had sex
he didn't really like pay attention to
or anything like that so
you can understand why she would be like
looking elsewhere
but that said you can also like be
pissed off at her
at how like catastrophically wrong her
choice of man was
um because it just ended up like it's
just
horrible horrible consequences that's
all i'm gonna say
so as i said if you're into gothic
literature and like i said this is like
a classic
gothic psychological thriller character
study type of thing not necessarily a
horror novel but
it is the consequences of the [ __ ] that
happens is
horrific um and it's just like
tragic and bleak and hopeless and just
like terrible things happen in it
and it will kind of make you feel bad
and like
make you feel shitty um so if that
sounds like something that you would
enjoy
if that's the right word to use um then
probably you will love this i really
really liked it i mean
it's not long i think it's only about
250 pages and i read it like i think in
just two sittings
um just because i found like like i said
even though the characters are like all
kind of
really really deeply shitty um other
than the kid he's all right
all the characters are so shitty but
they're but you can't stop
like watching them and it's so you know
what i mean it's like a slow-motion car
crash
type of thing this is what th that's
what this book is like
it's like watching a car crash in slow
motion
and you just can't look away so it's
it's like that kind of vibe
so if that sounds like that would be
your cup of tea
then by all means pick this up like i
said it came out in 1997
they made a movie about it they made a
movie adaptation of it in 2005
which has some like big actors in it but
apparently like got [ __ ] on
uh by critics i'm not entirely sure why
it might be terrible i don't know i'll
have to check it out
also somebody told me that the audiobook
had been narrated by sir ian mckellen
because some of the people on
goodreads had actually read the
audiobook so that might be worth
checking out too if you're into
audiobooks because he has like such a
lovely voice
but yeah so i would really like i can't
remember who it was that um
that recommended this book and this
author but uh thank you very much
because i really really did like this
book a lot
um i understand it's not gonna be
everyone's cup of tea like i said it
will make you feel really really bad
and uh it's very very depressing and
you're spending time with like some
deeply
[ __ ] up and unlikable people but that
said
it was its own the psychology in it is
really fascinating was like really
fascinating to me
so if that sounds like something like
just a deep dive
into like a terrible person's psyche as
they
just ruin everyone's lives around them
then
i would recommend this book if that does
not sound like fun then probably you
will not because this is not a fun book
i'm just saying that right now
um but i really really i was really
really into it
and i'll definitely be checking out some
more i'm pretty sure i've never read any
of his other stuff
even though like i said his name sounds
familiar i'll have to go back and look
on my
shelves because i've read so much [ __ ] i
can't like remember but uh but yeah
definitely check it out if it sounds
like your kind of thing and that'll do
it for this
episode and i'll see you on the next one
bye